so sieht es aus wenn einer der
bekanntesten österreichischen rapper
nach berlin kommt menschenauflauf uhr
und jetzt gleich der talk mit basar der
über sein leben seine ziele und noch in
er spricht gestand blatter
hallo
die lage sehr gut du bist jetzt aus wien
gekommen
und wo ist hier im schicken hotel am
platz ist dass ich glaube es hat lang
ist schon es gibt noch schritt aber es
ist schon ziemlich vom feinsten für mich
auch sehr wohl
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich damals
vor fünf jahren wir wollen hat musik zu
machen weil ich mit einem guten freunden
im dönerladen der ist kümmel türke den
gehsteigen in wien hin
damals gesagt weißt du was ich werde
jetzt anfangen damit und wenn ich das
mache ich werde hier alles niederreißen
ich werde ein eigenes monopol in
österreich sein niemand wieder mehr
vorbeikommen ganz egal wer christina
stimme könnt alle einpacken der eine
runde um mich herum zu kollegen die
haben sich zu tode gelacht so fantasie
wir werden sie die menschheit ist es
genauso ein gedrucktes ist kann man
bestens beschreiben es ist einfach geht
ein fortschritt so ich habe glaube ich
meine fans auf bewiesen dass unternehmen
sich immer vor den alten gesagt hat auch
dazu stehen konnte dass wir uns einfach
weiterentwickelt haben
es war bis jetzt glaube ich auch seit
zwei tagen im handel und ich habe eine
überwältigende resonanz darauf bekommen
deswegen haben wir glaube ich alles
richtig gemacht
natürlich weiß ich auch dass ich jung
bin und ein mensch bin der sehr exzessiv
lebt das heißt ich denke auch nicht dass
ich alt werden werde meistens nicht also
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht warum ich hier
will ich schon oft fälle gesehen habe wo
menschen alt geworden sind und dann
eigentlich nur noch so vor sich hin
vegetiert sind das möchte ich mir glaube
ich ein bisschen zu ersparen uns ich
habe das gefühl ich weiß ich seit jahren
schon habe ich immer das gefühl dass sie
nicht sehr alt werden werde und deswegen
jetzt in meinem jungen alter sozusagen
so viel wie möglich machen möchte auch
was mir spaß macht und was mir natürlich
auch geld ein
bringt um dann abseits der ganzen arbeit
ist auch mir dinge leisten zu können
schönen urlaub zu fliegen wie gesagt
wenn ich halt eben verreise auch
dementsprechend gut schlafen zu können
oder sonstiges zu tun und damit dann
passt es einfach auf meine chance kann
jedem passieren ist glaube ich aber eher
nicht ich glaube eher dass ich
gesundheitlich das nicht irgendwann
diesen lifestyle der nachhaltige mit was
jetzt nicht mit ruhm etwas zu tun also
ich bin absolut größte anti drogen typ
aber ich glaube einfach ich habe sehr
sehr wenig schlaf ich ernähre mich sehr
ungesund ich bin zu möglichen fast food
liebhaber dafür sieht aber ordentlich
macht natürlich auch ein bisschen sport
nebenbei ja aber deswegen glaube ich
einfach das kann ich also das bin ich
auch glaube ich meine eltern schuldig
wenn meine mama witt sterben glaube ich
wenn ich wenn ich ihr keine enkel bringe
sozusagen
deswegen versuche ich doch auch mein
bestes zu geben gibt es das schon
perspektiven ist noch noch ist die zeit
nicht reif ist nicht nur straße und
kampf und alles ist jetzt angesprochen
aber es gehört mit dem schuh hat
wirklich mit dazu ich sage mal die eine
oder andere schlagzeile die auch im
zusammenhang mit der leeze ist jetzt
nicht geht dann geht es nicht ums
kuscheln ja aber ich denke dass auch
meine musik sich mit meinem alter also
das immer mit gewachsen ist was jetzt
auch beim neuen album the fall war und
ich denke auch dass sie nächsten alten
genauso werden also die wachsen
definitiv mit mir und meinem alter war
auch wirst du dann irgendwann mal über
enkelkindern großeltern rappen hebel das
war richtig scheiße ja aber wenn der
punkt kommen würde denke ich mache ich
bestimmt auch keine musik mehr okay aber
wie gesagt die musik wechselt auch mit
mir und ich glaube ich bin auch schon
sehr weit davon distanziert von diesem
straße und kriegen und morgen gedanken
wie man es oft in der musiker
ich bin auch wirklich sehr sehr froh
dass jetzt halten mittlerweile seit ein
zwei jahren glaube ich auch schon der
trend gekommen ist dass dieses
ungewisser und um gefühle bei den fans
gar nicht mehr ankommt diese phase ist
vorbei
ich glaube es ist durch das man hat also
schon mal jeder hat sich schon mal leben
gesetzt es ist nichts neues ist richtig
lächerlich wenn du auch vor allem auch
wenn die typen wenn typen angegriffen
werden der musik die aber selber niemand
mal eingreifen
also dann sind die fans wirklich auch
schon so reif geworden dass sie sagen es
ist absolut lächerlich
jetzt gibt's dann rapper aus einer ganz
anderen richtung hat das also dass jetzt
so neue strömungen kommen hat das
eigentlich den rap so wiederbelebt kann
man das sagen
also nicht dass man sagt ich will jetzt
so sagen die crew aber dass man
gestaltet so ein bisschen ihr jetzt da
muss man mal wieder was es hat ihm sehr
geholfen ja also es hat definitiv
deutschen hiphop meiner meinung nach da
denken ja immer andere alles ein
bisschen anders drüber ich denke es ist
auf jeden fall sehr viel geholfen hat
ganz einfach weil leute wie casper
marteria es geschafft haben im plattform
reinzubekommen also rein zu kommen mit
ihrer musik und nicht nur weil er es
jemandem erschossen hat oder jemanden
bedroht hat sondern wirklich nur wegen
ihrer musik und ihrem auftreten was
einem breiten publikum präsentiert wurde
ich könnte jetzt nicht grob permanent
anhören ja ich finde es gut was er macht
weil es einfach gute vibes hatten gute
laune bringt aber wenn ich dann
ernsthaft in kommentaren leser von
leuten dass sie dann einfach beschimpfen
dass das so der ist dies und tester ich
kann das nicht verstehen wieso welt
definitiv kein einziger von den leuten
die ihn beleidigen kennen diesen typen
persönlich vor allem chronischen typ
denn niemanden beleidigt niemandem etwas
böses tut einfach nur fröhliche musik
macht damit erfolg hat und was hattest
du dich als fan zu interessieren ob der
erfolg hat oder nicht das heißt du wirst
hier in deutschland genauso wie in
österreich einfach dafür gehasst und
geredet wenn du erfolg hast und nicht
dem bild entspricht wie sie sich
wünschen kann meinen leitkultur werden
unfassbar unfassbar was also ist das ist
auch mein limit also dass das lieblings
nase aber 2012
unfassbar
laptop mit rappern gibt's auf dix um zum
beispiel den 257 dass die erzählen das
schließen
nackt aggressiver rappt was es damit auf
sich hat erfahrt ihr im druck mit den
dreien und warum man rtl mit eiern
bewerfen sollte das erzählt coldmirror
im talk also jetzt könnt ihr euch
entscheiden
2571 oder cola oder anders
eigentlich videos da da da ihr könnt
euch entscheiden sie selbst